البدايه من غزه حيث قال مراسل الجزيره ان
دخانا اسودا كثيفا ينبعث حاليا من جنوب
مدينه
غزه الصور التي
نشاهدها ونلاحظ من خلالها هذا الدخان
الاسود الكثيف الذي ينبعث من جنوب مدينه
غزه ونحاول ان
نقترب اك اكثر من ما يجري ونعرف تفاصيل ما
يحدث في جنوب غزه مع مراسلنا من غلاف غزه
الياس كرام الياس واضح هذا الدخان الاسود
من
خلفك وما نشاهده معك عبر الصور او عبر
الكاميرا كما تلتقطه من غلاف غزه ما الذي
يعرف عما يجري
هناك بالفعل وهو ياتي من الضاحيه الجنوبيه
لمدينه غزه على وجه الخصو من حي الزيتون
كما يبدو وواضح بان الدخان الاسود كثيف
جاء ذلك بعد ساعات ربما او ساعه من الهدوء
النسبي في هذه المنطقه لكن كان هنالك
تحليق كثيف ايضا للطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي في اجواء المنطقه وتبع ذلك
ايضا قصف مدفعي ليس واضحا فيما اذا كان
هذا الدخان الاسود ناجم عن هذه الطلعات
الجويه التي نفذها سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
في اجواء المنطقه في الدقائق الاخيره او
جراء القصف المدفعي لكن واضح بان الانفجار
كبير والدخان الاسود الذي ينبعث ايه
بكثافه من تلك ال المنطقه مؤشر على حجم
الانفجار الذي حدث لكن رغم ذلك ربما يكون
ايضا اشتباك مسلح من جانب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه واستهداف ايضا لاحدى الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه لا نستطيع ان نتحقق
من ذلك اي حقيقه من الموقع الذي نقف عنده
هنا في منطقه غلاف غزه سوى التاكيد على ان
هذا الانفجار كان كبيرا وحجم الدخان
الاسود المنبعث من تلك المنطقه يؤشر على
ذلك وهذه مناطق حقيقه تعرضت في الايام
الماضيه الى سلسله من الغارات الجويه
الكثيفه والمتتالية
حيث كانت القوات الاسرائيليه المتمركزه في
غلاف غزه قد استهدفت هذه المنطقه على مدار
ساعتين متواصلتين هذا عدا عن قصف متقطع
كانت كان طيله نهار يوم امس اذا المناطق
الجنوبيه تحديدا في مدينه غزه في اليومين
الاخيرين هي هدف للقوات الاسرائيليه
بالاضافه ايضا الى بعض الاحياء الجنوبيه
الغربيه لمدينه غزه التي كثف الطيران
الحربي الاسرائيلي غاراته الجويه عليها
وتزامن ذلك ايضا مع اعلان الجيش
الاسرائيلي وطلبه الى السكان الفلسطينيين
في الاحياء الغربيه لمدينه غزه تحديدا
الاحياء الغربيه الجنوبيه منها مغادره هذه
الاحياء الى المناطق الامنه في منطقه دير
البلح وهذا في اطار طبعا التهجير القصري
الذي يتعمد الجيش الاسرائيلي القيام به في
كل مره يعمق من عملياته العسكريه اي في
مناطق مختلفه في قطاع غزه وهذا الانفجار
الذي يحصل في مدينه غزه يؤكد على ان
المعارك المعارك العسكريه هنا في المناطق
الشماليه للقطاع تحديدا لم تنتهي بعد وان
خفت وهذا ايضا ما تؤكده بيانات الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي يقول بانه رغم انتقال
الجيش الاسرائيلي الى المرحله الثالثه من
عملياته العسكريه والتي يفترض انها اقل
زخما مما شهدناه في الاسابيع والشهور
الاخيره الا اننا ما زلنا نسمع اشتباكات
مسلحه بين الحين والاخر في الضواحي
الشرقيه لمدينه غزه في احياء مختلفه من
المدينه حتى في اقصى المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه في بيت حنون وفي بيت لهيه كانت
هنالك اشتباكات ما بين الجيش الاسرائيلي
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه في اكثر من موقع وفي
اكثر من مكان الان نرى في منطقه جباليا
بان الجيش الاسرائيلي يلقي بعض القنابل
المضيئه فوق جباليا وهذا ربما يؤ يدلل على
ان شيئا ما يحدث هناك ايضا في في جباليا
على اعتبار ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل من
عمليات العسكريه وهذه القنبله قنبله
الاناره اطلقت في موقع كان قد استهدف قبل
نحو ساعه تقريبا بقذيفه مدفعيه على ما
يبدو وكانت تنبعث من هذك من تلك المنطقه
اعمده الدخان يبدو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يريد ان يؤشر على تلك المنطقه لتحديدها
ربما للمدفع فعيه الاسرائيليه من اجل
القيام بقصفها مجددا او لاستدعاء الطيران
الحربي الاسرائيلي لقصفها عاده يجري ذلك
عندما تكون القوات الاسرائيليه في الميدان
قد علقت في مازق ما او في مرطه ما او في
مصيده او كمين للمقاومه الفلسطينيه هي تق
تقوم باطلاق هذه القنابل المضيئه من اجل
الاشاره ربما الى موقعها لمنع استهدافها
من جانب المدفعيه الاسرائيليه او الطيران
الحربي الاسرائيلي او بالعكس الاشاره الى
هذا الموقع من اجل قصفه بالمدفعيه او
بالطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي وانقاذ ربما
الجنود العالقين في تلك المنطقه في اطار
عمليات المواجهه المستمره وجها الى وجه مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في اكثر من موقع
واكثر من مكان حتى هذا اليوم بمعنى ان ما
نشهده في الساعات ال 24 الماضيه حقيقه وما
شهدناه حتى في المناطق الوسطى لقطاع غزه
عند المخيمات التي شهدت بالام ايضا قصفا
مدفعيا شديدا جدا هذا يعني بان المعارك لم
لم تنتهي وان خفت وهنالك ايام تمر يكون
فيها الهدوء سيد الموقف رايت في الاطلاله
السابقه ان الهدوء كان يعم كل المنطقه
الشماليه لساعه او ساعتين واذ بهذا
الانفجار الكبير في المنطقه الجنوبيه
لمدينه غزه يعيد الامور الى المربع الاول
الى مربع المواجهه والاشتباك واندلاع هذه
المواجهات من جديد اذا من من جديد تستمر
عمليات اطلاق الاناره على هذا الموقع في
في جباليا يبدو ان شيئا ما يحدث هناك
وعاده كما اشرت ان هذا استخدام قنابل
الاناره في وضح النهار هو ايضا وسيله
للاشاره الى موقع الجنود الاسرائيليين
الذين يعملون وينشطون عسكريا وربما ايضا
للاشاره للطيران الحربي وللمدعي
الاسرائيليه لضرب مواقع ربما يكون يتحصن
فيها مقاومون فلسطينيون ويواجهون القوات
الاسرائيليه وحقيقه بان هذه المواقع التي
تستهدف الان بقنابل الاناره كانت قد شهدت
في الاسابيع الماضيه اشتباكات عنيفه ما
بين الجيش الاسرائيلي والمقاومه ال
الفلسطينيه وكانت ايضا تتعرض في كثير من
الاحيان لقصف جوي كثيف ولقصر مدفعي كثيف
اذا رغم اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي الانتقال
الى مراحل اقل زخما من حيث المعارك
العسكريه
وايضا بموازاه ذلك تقليل اعداد الجنود
خاصه في صفوف الاحتياط الا ان المعارك ما
زالت على قدم وساق تشتد حينا وتخف احيانا